can presidents be polite over dinner it
may not happen to many of us but they're
surely nothing worse than turning up to
a party and having a prime minister
start complaining about your
government's crackdown on a sanctions
busting bank but President Barack Obama
has precisely that to look forward to
tonight when he breaks bread with French
leader Francois Hollande the bank in
question BNP Paribas faced the 10
billion dollar fine from American
authorities for client transfers that
allegedly violated US sanctions against
Iran Sudan oh Cuba France's foreign
minister says that the fine higher than
the bank's estimated annual earnings is
unreasonable would limit the np's
capital and curb the bank's ability to
lend to French businesses but that
awkward encounter can barely compared to
a possible meeting between Obama and
Russian President Vladimir Putin after
an attempted reset of US Russia
relations several years ago the crisis
in Ukraine has really appended those
efforts these days Obama's warning
Russia against provocation and Putin
says he's worried about a return to the
Cold War but with all three presidents
in Paris this week it will be more about
the cold shoulder president Hollande
will host President Obama and President
Putin in the same city on the same night
but they'll be eating at separate
dinners for lightly of course